ladies and gentlemen on behalf of the  1922 committee charles walker and i as  returning officers of the election for  the leader of the conservative and  unionist party can now declare the  results of the second ballot the total  number of votes cast in today's ballot  was 313 the total number of ballot  papers rejected was again 0 the total  number of votes given to each candidate  in alphabetical order were as follows  Michael Gove 41 Jeremy Hunt 46 Sajid  Javid 33 Boris Johnson 126 Dominick rabe  30 Rory Stewart 37  therefore the following candidates are  now eligible to continue on to the next  ballot on Wednesday the 19th of June at  3:00 p.m. Michael Gove Jeremy hunt  Sajid Javid Boris Johnson and Rory  Stewart thank you very much